le zéro absolu me paraît un horizon
compliqué est-ce qu'il faut réduire les
phyos la réponse est oui parce que vous
avez dit ça va être un peu ça notre
trame euh j'en suis euh j'en suis
complètement d'accord alors réduire vous
avez raison de dire 20 % ou 30 % c'est
une étape ça c'est notamment par le
matériel par les pratiques on doit y
arriver dès qu'on arrive à à 50 on est
sur la reconception des modèles donc ça
c'est toutes les fermes de référence les
structures avec les filières les
instituts techniques linreay enfin bon
là on a quelque chose de beaucoup plus
solide est-ce qu'on peut dire que à 2050
on peut se passer totalement de phyo
d'abord je vourrais pardon je peut-être
choquer certains ici ce serait donc
l'agriculture serait le seul secteur
d'activité qui qui ne pourrait pas
utiliser de produits de produits de
nature chimique parce que je veux dire
il y a pas une un secteur
d'activité de nature humaine de nature
industrielle qui n'utilise pas des
produits chimiques donc je j'interroge
quand même la question de dire le zéro
absolu comme horizon comme injonction
vous avez pas dit injonction vous mais
vous avez interrogé moi je vous dis non
mais je vous dis juste je trouve que
c'est curieux qu'on fasse appliquer à
l'agriculture ce qu'on ne demande pas au
produits pharmaceutique dont on se
soigne sont des produits chimiques qu'on
ne demande pas à la plasturgie qu'on ne
demande pas
il me semble qu'il y a quelque chose
quand même le zéro absolu me paraît un
horizon compliqué je le dis d'autant
plus qu'il faut quand même qu'on se
préserve et on le voit dans un certain
nombre d'impasses qu'on produit on peut
avoir des accidents climatiques qui
fassent que certaines années on on a un
besoin de recours aux usages des
produits phyo pour juste pas perdre
toutes les récoltes je le dis aussi
simplement que ça est-ce que c'est
techniquement possible j'ai répondu oui
je pense que c'est techniquement
possible c'est plutôt du combinatoire
qu'un seule solution mais vous le savez
mieux que moi et vous le savez aussi
bien que moi donc et est-ce que alors
vous m'avez toujours trouvé sur le
chemin de dire ne disons pas on peut pas
faire la la souveraineté alimentaire si
jamais on réduit les phyos on peut faire
la souveraineté alimentaire en réduisant
les phyos sous la réserve que on ne
mette pas les gens face à des impasses
et qu'on leur dise pas vous avez une
alternative quand ils n'en ont pas il y
a des ici dans cette salle des gens qui
connaissent le sujet
je suis désolé de dire que nous n'avons
pas aujourd'hui d'alternative qui ne soi
pas trop impactant de rendement sur la
betterave et j'ai maintenu quand même
les positions nous n'avons pas
d'alternative aujourd'hui crédiible sur
la sererise sans doute avons-nous pris
trop de retard sur ces sujets là ça pose
cette question là de dire on sait que
cette molécule là quand je vois que
parfois on me r réclame le dimettoat et
le faus m qui ont été interdit il y a
plus d'une dizaine d'années je me dis
que y compris intellectuellement et nous
comme responsable public on n' pas fait
le chemin qu'il fallait pour dire on va
trouver des solutions à ces je sais pas
quel pays fait mieux que
nous donc c'est je m'inspire du modèle
français et il faut il faut le dire aux
agriculteurs aussi parce que c'est assez
déplorable de voir les débats qu'on a
chez nous quand je parle avec mes autres
collègues ils sont fascinés de voir les
débats qu'on a chez nous hein par qu'il
nous regardent en disant mais pourtant
vous êtes très avancé hein sur des tas
de sujets et il y a un moment la corde
rond avec le monde agricole à cause de
ça faut arrêter de dénigrer ça veut pas
dire que ne pas dénigrer ça veut pas
dire qu'il y a pas des March de progrès
et pas des encouragements à la
transition mais quand vous passez votre
temps à dire les produits sont mauvais
même le bi mainant vous des reportages
pour dire c'est affreux on a mis des
produits bah oui le bio met des produits
oui oui c'est pas pas pu c'est des
produits qui sont parfois toxiques même
s'ils sont naturels quand ils sont à
haute dose comme le reste bon donc faut
qu'on apprenne tout ça collectivement et
le modèle inspirant pour moi est un
modèle français sous réserve que il est
soit viable économiquement sinon il sera
pas inspirant il sera juste comment
dirais un de modèle
[Musique]
inspirant
comp glyphosate c'est bien pour ça que
la position française a été celle-là la
Commission européenne vient de suite au
vote qui a été conforme à ce qui avait
été la dernière fois vient de dire
qu'elle réautorisait sur 10 an dans les
conditions qui sont les ciels nous nous
continuerons à trouver notre trajectoire
au travers des efforts qui ont été fait
on va pas revenir en arrière sur le
sujet